do you think because it that infuriates
me
all right it infuriates me it i it broke
my heart
it breaks my heart to get to get my
special passed on broke my heart in
hindsight yeah is the
[ __ ] best thing that ever happened to
me because i want to let you know steve
is is that i'll just say it i was
pitching a show at netflix with joe coy
and and howie mandel is
with us because he's producing the thing
that joe and i and how he's like these
two are
very good stand-ups and the executives
in the room looked at me and they go
you do stand up to me
and this is seven eight months ago
okay my heart cracked into my body
and it melted into my [ __ ] soul right
my point is is that
don't take it personally right that they
passed on it well
i mean of course i i you know
take it personally i know
the guy who's in charge of buying
comedy specials at netflix even went so
far
as to uh to explicitly say
i am a comedy snob and i only am
interested in buying comedy specials
from lifelong pure
stand-up comedians of which i do not
consider stevo to be
so it's like hey man i gotta at least
give him credit for you yeah okay not
[ __ ] sugar coating
yeah yeah
hey man at least you at least you just
said what it was and now
i i doubled down i did the bucket list
tour
i just [ __ ] went all out now now like
one of my bucket list ideas was to go
skydiving butt naked with a guy strapped
on my back the tandem dude
while i'm jacking off yeah and time it
so that i'm falling out of the airplane
blowing alone all over everybody
yeah yeah and i did it oh you did it
it's called skyjack okay
let me ask you something because it's
like if i'm masturbating
yeah right and i hear a little creak
right or a little wind i get thrown off
right you're right
imagine a plane full of dudes all
pointing cameras at you
like how do you did you take viagra i
took four cialis tablets yeah there we
go
right did you watch porn yeah i brought
a portable dvd
that was my dvd that was the one
exception well because you're not going
to get a wi-fi
signal 15 000 feet yeah wait do you
start jerking off
in the plane how long before the jump um
or do you start to jump
did this was the craziest part about it
was that
like i had to [ __ ] there's
a window of of like was it
two minutes a window
where like if it's gotta happen you
gotta leave the plane within that two
minutes
otherwise you're not going to be over
the drop zone
so i had to [ __ ] time it dude oh my
god i had to time it it had
so i was like okay give me
[ __ ] three minutes notice give me one
minute before the two minutes starts
so they scream t minus three and i
[ __ ] start going for it man
like uh but you have to focus right oh
yeah
and then dude like it it was heavy dude
it was it was
it was the most as far as like
multimedia like where it's like a funny
story
trying to find the [ __ ] company that
would sign off on it trying to find the
guy who's willing to be strapped to my
back
trying to logistically pull it off in a
plane full of dudes
like actually how it happened like the
most hilarious stand-up comedy bit
and the footage to back it up is just
next level
but that's that's one of the many things
i did for the bucket list tour
and that was all happened while i was
just sitting
on the gnarly special wow i was just
sitting on it and i was like [ __ ]
trying to figure it out like okay now
how am i gonna
you know i spent so much money on it i
can't just give it away and even if i
was inclined to give it away i can't put
it on youtube it won't last [ __ ]
60 seconds on there before they [ __ ]
take it down and yeah you know
and so it took me this long and only
like just
very recently it just went up i figured
out the paywall
you know it's streaming at and
and to promote it i bought a billboard
right here in hollywood
wow i hired a [ __ ] crew like a
construction crew that builds gas
stations
with two [ __ ] cranes you know i'll
even tell you how much the billboard
cost 8 000 bucks just to rent the
billboard
and then two cranes a whole [ __ ]
construction crew they built this
[ __ ] thing for me to stand on
like flew out uh this [ __ ] killer
photographer the whole
like i hired a publicist to [ __ ] you
know like and
by the time i got done like getting this
special out
like i was totally 300 000 into oh my
god and now i'm gonna do this [ __ ]
billboard stunt where
let's face it they're a pretty strong
chance
that uh i'm gonna have to hire another
[ __ ] criminal attorney
[Laughter]
like and that the expenses are just
gonna get [ __ ]
overwhelming yeah and i'm like [ __ ] it
dude i'm gonna show
those [ __ ] [ __ ] who [ __ ]
rejected this thing
i'm gonna [ __ ] make that i'm gonna
[ __ ] force them to deal
with the entire [ __ ] world knowing
about my
gnarly special and i went up and i got
[ __ ] duct taped to that billboard
and within 48 hours i had articles
online from variety
vanity fair rolling stone
tmz buzzfeed deadline cnn
people extra e online [ __ ]
usa today [ __ ]
the whole goddamn world knows about my
[ __ ] gnarly comedy special
and um the the cops all the people they
they showed up and they looked at us and
they said oh well there's no crime being
committed here he's taped to his own
[ __ ] billboard
yeah he bought the thing yeah yeah yeah
like
which is crazy and and and i did have a
lawyer go over the contract with the
billboard company
and it's their dumb ass [ __ ] father
yeah no language whatsoever
about anything to do with that plus the
image that they approved which was on
the billboard
was an image of me duct tape to the
billboard all we did was [ __ ] duct
tape me over me
oh yeah so they approved the art
oh
the cops said there's no crime here but
what happened that was upsetting to me
was that the uh the
fire department shows up right now we
kept our two cranes
they're called cherry picker cranes you
see like the phone company guys in them
you know it's like a little thing and uh
we kept them on site
so that we could take me down ourselves
like i didn't want to be involved in
wasting the city's resources you know
like and so i had my construction team
on site with the cranes
when the first responders showed up they
went straight over they said hey there's
nothing to worry about here
he's on there with like [ __ ] five
points of [ __ ] harness
carabiners clipped on the [ __ ] the
the shelf he's standing on is
like suspended by straps that are rated
for over five thousand pounds of weight
like he's he's on there we've got cranes
we can get him down no problem we don't
want to waste your time
the fire department sadly said we have
to be the ones to give it
for liability issues we've got to take
them down and i'm like
oh this is what i didn't want yeah when
i heard that they have to take me down
i'd like i got them to send me up a
knife i cut away the tape i was like hey
guys come on let's
and and i i did legitimately feel like
like a piece of [ __ ] for having the fire
department working on getting me down
from my billboard
yeah so what i did was i took a uh the
dopest photo that that photographer i
hired and flew out
the dopest photo that he took and i had
it like them like cleaned up so that
there wasn't a bunch of loud [ __ ]
it's dope as print i bought a thousand
of them
and i saw them on my website for 25
dollars a piece signed everyone
signed so all thousands went with
within less than 48 hours and that was
25 000 raised which i matched
with my own 25 000 for a total of 50
000 that today i donated to the los
angeles fire department oh cool man
yeah so it's like kind of like i got to
clean up my mess a little bit yeah
there's the only [ __ ] part of the
plan that sucked the one thing that
tainted this
epic publicity stunt was the fire
department showed up and [ __ ] had to
waste their time on me yeah
and so i donated 50 [ __ ] grand to
them today
and as i was driving i posted the
[ __ ] [ __ ] while i was driving here
oh yeah i hate to be texting and driving
i was [ __ ] i was
cramming dude i grabbed my [ __ ]
picture of me with the fire chief dude
holding up this this obnoxious oversized
chair yeah yeah
on the check i'm talking yeah yeah yeah
i'm so stoked on it man and um you know
it's so
so i feel good about that part of it and
and [ __ ] yeah
like and dad i shouldn't even like
i i should just let it be but but the
thing is that
the [ __ ] everybody who who
rejected my special
the the quarter million part that i
spent producing it
i mean i i'll just say i i sat on the
[ __ ] thing for two and a half years i
taped it in january of 2018.
wow wow so so come all this time later
that [ __ ] quarter million it's been
out the door
so long ago i don't even [ __ ]
consider it missing yeah you know
i was like dude anything i get for this
from
distributing it on my own website yeah
it's all bonus it's all gravy
i think you'll get it back i i already
had it back by the time i was on the
billboard
yeah yeah and and and uh
okay i i already had brought in
over 300 000 in revenue by the time
that the cherry picker cranes went up
with the crew that attached me to the
billboard yeah
and um that that was
when i started [ __ ] kicking more ass
with that
yeah because the whole [ __ ] world
knew about it
good good good and and [ __ ] them yeah
man
not the fire department [ __ ] everybody
you didn't believe in this before you
leave though i want to ask you a
question though i have a few questions
too i have a
couple of questions yeah and and you
know what like i'll even say that i'm
crazy
to see this i don't [ __ ] you know
like uh if
if people i stream it for 9.99
at stevo.com everyone listening right
now he's our boy i love him so much
he's so funny [ __ ] go to
his website and [ __ ] stream gnarly
yeah no like i hired the same
anti-piracy
company that all the movie studios hire
you know like
they they just said candidly it's not
possible to completely scrub it away if
people are really determined to
to watch it for free they will yeah and
if people don't want don't have 9.99
they want a [ __ ] one
by all means go over but i did
everything in my power to make that
difficult
yeah to make it just easier to pay the
[ __ ] 9.99
yeah i would appreciate it if people did
yeah you know because i
really have oh they will i have a
[ __ ] axe to grind i know
and and and you know the other thing how
my first special was all about this
journey to to learn how to have a
healthy relationship
the last thing that happened on stage at
this
on this news special the gnarly special
the last thing that happens on that
stage is i get on my knee
and i propose to my girl in front of all
my
family and friends when is a wedding we
don't have a
date yet because we're we're determined
to buy a property and open up our own
animal sanctuary
and we're going to get married on that
property
are kaleila and i invited to the wedding
absolutely we are going to go 100
absolutely it might be the only wedding
i
look forward to just because it's
inanimate thank you
we we're not having kids because one of
my bucket list items was called the
vasectomy olympics
it's tied up yeah it's snipped it's nip
you can un
you can reverse it you can you can
extract from the balls
extract from the balls yeah you can't
extract i don't want to no you're
i think you should have children nah
yeah yeah
i i honestly think you would be a good
great father
listen because look at how far you've
come